yeah I mean but honestly if Leon's
saying he wants to fight in Abu Dhabi
and he's he said Abu Dhabi coming out of
his mouth and he said I don't want to
fight Kobe and I go out there and I
finish Gilbert Burns it's like you have
to put me in Abu Dhabi against Leonards
the time will be perfect Leon wants to
fight there having me fight there and
Arab fighting in Abu Dhabi for a title
it's different to having an Arab fight
in Abu Dhabi in front of his people
would be bigger than anything you could
do I also think it puts the pressure on
Dana White I know he's pretty steadfast
on Kobe Covington getting this title
shot but if you go out there and you
make a convincing push and you you
finish Gilbert Burns which is damn hard
to do and you beat Gilbert and you give
him a freaking promo towards Leon
Edwards UFC's Mike all right man all
right he's done everything there's
nothing else you can't hold this guy
back any long